ERIN SCHAEFER: Good
morning, everybody.
I'm Erin Schaefer.
I work on our global brand
solutions team, a part
of the broader YouTube crew.
Let me tell you a little
bit about Arianna.
I'm sure many of you
already know a lot of this.
But Arianna is the co-founder,
president, and editor-in-chief
of Huffington Post Media Group.
She launched the
Huffington Post in 2005
and in 2012 the site
won a Pulitzer--
the first for a
digital media company--
incredibly impressive-- for
their national reporting.
Arianna also, in
all her free time,
has been a very busy author.
She's the author of 15 books.
And her 15th, and most
recent, that we're
going to talk a
little bit about today
is "The Sleep Revolution," which
is about the science, history
and mystery of sleep.
And I know we'll
dig into that a bit.
You also probably
know that Arianna
has been named to "Time"
magazine's list of the 100
most influential people and
the Forbes most powerful women
list.
She's on numerous boards,
including the Center
for Public Integrity and Uber.
And she's also
originally from Greece,
having moved to
England when she was
16, where she graduated from
Cambridge with a masters--
an MA in economics.
And again, I've only had
the pleasure of meeting her
just this morning, but I
already feel that we're
close friends after 15 minutes.
She's a very, very
special person.
With that, Arianna,
please come on up.
How about a hug?
Thank you so much
for joining us here.
I'm thrilled to have you.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: I'm
just thrilled to be here.
And I'm so happy
that everybody seems
to be getting a copy of
"The Sleep Revolution."
ERIN SCHAEFER: Yes.
We're sorry not everybody
on GVD can do that,
but you, too, should
get a copy of the book.
What I'll do is I'll
ask you a few questions
and then I'll open
it up to our audience
here, and then the many
people who've asked questions
from around the
globe on our Dory.
But let me get started here.
And I'd love to start with
this book and "The Sleep
Revolution."
Can you tell us a bit
about your motivation
for writing a book about sleep?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
My motivation
was that I actually collapsed
from sleep deprivation.
And on my way down,
broke my cheekbone
on a corner of my desk.
And as I came to,
in a pool of blood,
I had to ask myself the
question, if you come
to in a pool of blood
and nobody has shot you,
is that really what
success looks like?
And that led to a book I wrote
two years ago, called "Thrive."
And in "Thrive,"
sleep is a tiny part.
And as I went around
the world, speaking
about redefining success
and including our well-being
and sense of wonder and giving
into the definition, what
people really wanted to
talk about was sleep.
Because we share it.
It's like it's the universal
common denominator.
You may not want to
meditate or wonder or give,
but you have to sleep.
So I decided to dig deep
and make the book very much
based on all the latest
science about sleep.
Because it's kind of amazing.
Sleep is a very new science.
In fact, the first
scientific sleep center
was founded here at
Stanford in 1970.
And now there are over
2,500 in the US alone.
And the conclusion--
as you'll see,
there are 1,200 scientific
footnotes in the book.
You don't have to
actually read them,
but if you have a
partner or a friend who
is skeptical about sleep,
you can make them read them.
Because it's kind of
unequivocal and conclusive.
The science is saying
sleep is not negotiable.
And it's not something
you can choose
to do or not do unless you
have a genetic mutation.
About 1% of the population
has a genetic mutation
and they can do great on
four and five hours' sleep.
I don't have that
genetic mutation.
And you cannot train yourself
to have a genetic mutation.
But there is actually a choice
before your children are born.
You have two children, but if
you want to have a third one
and you want them to
be a short sleeper--
I don't know why you
would, but if you--
you can do gene editing
before the baby is born.
Once the baby is
born, the die is cast.
That's it.
Seven to nine hours.
Where you are in
that spectrum is
individual, but seven to nine.
ERIN SCHAEFER: What is
the revolution itself?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
The revolution
is really changing the culture.
Because we are all living
under the collective delusion--
and you experience
it more than anyone,
here in the valley--
that in order to succeed,
you have to burn out.
That's the delusion
of our culture.
You go into companies and you
see people being congratulated
for working 24/7,
people wear being busy
like a badge of honor.
People say, she's amazing.
She's always on.
She returns texts and
emails right away.
And we need to change that.
We need to change how we
hear something like that.
Now if I hear someone
say, she's amazing.
She's always on.
I think, that's a problem.
And it's a problem
on many levels.
It's a problem because at some
point, that someone on person
is going to burn
out, mathematically.
And the form the
burnout takes will vary.
It can be a collapse like mine.
It can be a health issue.
It can be any number of things.
Even a lot of the accidents
that happen that we think
are accidents are really because
our immune system is down
or we're not paying
attention, et cetera.
And the other thing is
that this whole building
is like a celebration
of creativity.
YouTube is a
celebration of creators.
The first thing
that gets degraded
if you're sleep-deprived
is your creativity.
You can still be
a transactional.
You can still go to
meetings and pay attention
with half your brain and
make notes and show up.
But really, the part of
you that really comes up
with innovative,
game-changing ideas-- which
is why you are all about--
is not functioning as well.
So we need to rethink our
whole idea of what it means
to be optimally performing.
And you know what I love?
That athletes, who are all
about performance and winning,
are now prioritizing sleep
and renewal and recharging.
I write a lot about Andre
Iguodala in the book
because he actually tracked
his stats after he started
getting eight hours' sleep.
And it's just amazing to
see the immediate impact
on performance.
So sleep as a
performance enhancer.
Now sleep is a lot
more than that.
But I don't really care why
you start getting enough sleep.
Whatever your entry
point is, take it.
One of the lines in
the book is "come
for the performance-enhancing
benefits,
stay for the
life-enhancing benefits."
And for me, the biggest
life-enhancing benefit
is actually bringing joy
into what you're doing.
Because I feel we're
all so blessed--
we have jobs we love--
to be living here.
And so often, I know for
myself, when I'm sleep-deprived,
I may still get things
done, but the joy is gone.
I drag myself through the day.
I just go through the motions.
But I'm not really in it.
ERIN SCHAEFER: Yes.
You're sleepwalking
through life,
but not really experiencing it.
I want to talk a
little bit about media,
so I want to go back to a time
when you certainly were not
sleepwalking through anything,
when you started the Huffington
Post.
You started it in 2005.
What do you think led it to
become so successful, when
there were already a lot of
other online news platforms
out there?
What was it about
the Huffington Post
that attracted so many readers?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
I think what it
was is really what is at
the heart of YouTube, which
is that we are a platform,
from the beginning.
Yes, we're also a
journalistic enterprise
that, a few years
later, won a Pulitzer
and we now have 850 journalists,
editors, in 16 countries.
But the fact that we were a
platform where people could
come and create--
tell their stories
and share them-- was really
what differentiated us
from the beginning.
And that we did that, not as a
free-for-all, but making sure
that the best thing's
got the most attention
and that there was no
hierarchy, except is
this really worth amplifying?
Is this worth sharing?
Whether it was President
Obama or a homeless student
with something interesting to
say, which actually happened.
And that homeless student
wrote a beautiful blog post
which happened to be seen by
the Harvard admissions office
and he's now in his
third year at Harvard.
So immediately,
you saw the magic
of what was happening in
this digital revolution--
that people were discovered.
Look at all the stars
that YouTube has created.
Where would they be were
it not for this platform?
Yeah, they might get
an agent in Hollywood,
but now you don't need
an agent in Hollywood.
You don't need a publisher.
You can actually be
your own publisher
and you can be your own creator
and you can be discovered.
ERIN SCHAEFER:
Yes, I think there
are a lot of similarities
between the Huffington
Post as a platform and YouTube.
And it is all about
just giving people
a chance to have their voice.
Obviously, looking
backwards to 2005,
a lot has changed in
the media industry.
What have you noticed
over the last-- not just
those 10 years-- but your
history in the media industry?
And what do you think
is going to happen
next, in the next five
to 10 years in media?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: I
think what's happening now,
as you know, is that
there's so much.
There's so many platforms.
There is so much noise that
I think what is happening,
and what's going to
become increasingly
important in the next
few years, is are you
adding value to people's lives?
And at Huff Post, we've
taken that to heart.
And we've divided
everything we're doing
into three editorial pillars.
The first is, obviously,
news and politics,
but with our own perspective.
We're not covering this
election the way others are
covering this election.
From day one, we refused
to treat Donald Trump
as a normal candidate.
We feel this is very
important for journalists
not to buy into the idea that
our job is to be in the middle
and present you two
sides to the story.
Because you know what?
Not everything has two sides.
Evolution is a fact.
The earth is not flat.
Barack Obama was born
in the United States.
Global warming is real.
And yet, far too
many journalists
are having these
conversations where
you have a scientist
who believes
in global warming debating
a scientist who doesn't, as
though this is a
legitimate debate.
So from day one,
when Donald Trump
decided he's running
for president,
we started covering him in
the entertainment section,
on the grounds that-- as Seth
Meyers said at the White House
Correspondents' Dinner in 2011,
when Donald Trump first said
he was running for president.
He said, I just heard that
Donald Trump is running
for president as a Republican.
I thought he was running
for president as a joke.
The day that he
actually pronounced
this policy of banning
1.6 billion Muslims
from this country, we
stopped covering him
in the entertainment
section and we cover him
as a clear and present
danger to this country.
And at the end of
every story that
mentions him, there
is an editor's note
that says, we want to remind our
readers that Donald Trump wants
to ban an entire religion
from this country,
is regularly inciting
violence, is a serial sexist
misogynist and
xenophobe who does not
believe that the President
of the United States
was born here.
And this is our job.
Our job is to keep
reminding voters who he is.
Voters will do whatever they're
going to do in November.
But it cannot be because the
media have not done their job.
As you can see, the way we
approach our politics and news
pillar is very different.
The second pillar is
covering solutions.
We think there is
way too much coverage
of problems and crisis.
And obviously, we cover those.
But there is an amazing amount
of good happening in the world.
There is an amazing amount
of innovation and creativity
and compassion.
And we need to cover
those things, too.
So we have a big editorial
department called
What's Working?
And at the heart of that
is also encouraging people
to take action.
And Susan and I have
been talking about that,
how there's so much
amazing stuff on YouTube
and how can we encourage people
immediately to take action?
Because sometimes
you watch a video
and you feel compelled
to do something
and then life intervenes.
If you don't do it
right away, it's
going to be harder to do it.
So we're working with
Crowdrise, and we're
working with Jordan Hewson's
Action Button and the Global
Poverty Project Button to
make all these stories more
actionable.
And the third thing
is all our initiatives
around wellness and reducing
burnout and all the things
that we've been discussing
in the first part
of our conversation.
ERIN SCHAEFER: Do
you think the way
that Huff Post and
others will deliver
that content--
interact with viewers
and readers of that
content-- will that change?
What do you see happening
in the next 5 to 10 years,
in terms of how the media works
and how consumers of the media
interact with it?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
Well, I think
what's been happening
is going to accelerate.
And of course, you are right
in the middle of these changes.
More and more of this content is
going to be consumed on mobile.
More and more of it
is going to be video.
And more and more of it is going
to come to readers and viewers
through the back door.
Instead of them
going to a site, it's
going to be because their
friends are sharing it
or some other social
action that makes
them aware of that content.
And we see that at
the Huffington Post.
I think the Huffington Post's
probably the last major media
site that still has
destination traffic.
But we see it
declining every year.
We've actually focused more
on our off-platform traffic,
on the grounds that ubiquity
is the new exclusivity,
is what we're saying.
It's not really about
exclusive content.
We love partnerships.
We love crossposting
both letting
others crosspost our
content and crossposting
the content of others.
I think all these trends
that are already present
are going to accelerate.
ERIN SCHAEFER: Being where the
people are and making it easy--
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Exactly.
ERIN SCHAEFER: --for
them to get to you.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
And then, also,
shaping the content in ways
appropriate for whatever
platform you're going
to see the content.
ERIN SCHAEFER: Makes
a lot of sense.
Getting back to the news
pillar just for a moment,
I would wonder, what would
you tell a young person
today who is interested in
getting into journalism?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
I would say go for it
and don't even wait to
go to journalism school.
Just start where you
are because journalism
has so dramatically changed that
it's really about the stories
you tell.
And then using the amazing
technology available
to tell these stories
with more impact.
We just bought a VR
company called RYOT.
And the reason we chose
them is because they
care about the
stories having impact
and not just using
the technology
to make it all beautiful
and appealing to people.
And in the same
sense, if you want
to go into journalism to have an
impact-- whether the impact is
in politics or
entertainment or any field--
this is the golden
age of journalism.
ERIN SCHAEFER: So
news still matters.
And in fact, you have more
tools, as a journalist,
available to you
than ever before.
OK.
Thank you.
I want to turn to some
questions about leadership.
You have been
phenomenally successful
in such a variety
of different areas.
But I'm sure, along
with everybody else,
you've had a lot of lessons
along the way from setbacks,
et cetera.
Can you tell us about some
of the lessons that you've
learned, both from the
success and from times
where you've struggled a bit?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Absolutely.
I was very lucky that I had a
mother-- when I was growing up
in Athens, Greece in a
one-bedroom apartment
with no money-- who
always made me believe
that I could take risks and that
it didn't matter if I failed.
Because I think what
stops us, very often,
from taking risks and
going for our dreams
is that we don't want to fail.
Especially women.
For some reason, we
women want to be perfect.
And we're not.
Nobody is.
Recognizing that failure,
as my mother used to say,
is not the opposite of
success, but a stepping stone
to success.
That changes the way
we approach everything.
For me, I would
say that the thing
I've struggled the
most all my life
is the voice inside my head that
I call the obnoxious roommate
living in my head.
ERIN SCHAEFER: We
also have those.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
We all have it.
Yes.
But you can really
work on that voice
and you can really make
sure that that voice only
gets guest appearances.
And actually just to
link it back to sleep,
when I'm sleep-deprived--
which now, I have to say,
only happens about
5% of the time--
that voice becomes intensified.
So that's another thing.
When we're rested and
recharged, that voice
doesn't have as
much sway over us
because we don't
identify with it.
And so that voice of
self-doubt, of questioning
what we are doing, is the most
draining thing in our lives.
So if you notice
it, it's not really
what we do that's
exhausting, it's
really what our mind
does before and after.
Before it's worrying-- if you
take our conversation today.
My mind, beforehand,
can go into worry,
anxiety-- are they going
to like what I'm saying?
Am I going to remember
everything I want to say?
All these things that
are monkey mind does.
And then when we finish--
I love being here.
This is fun.
This is not work.
I talk about something I love.
You are fabulous.
I'm meeting somebody new.
And I look forward
to your questions.
It's great.
But if, then, I leave and my
mind-- the obnoxious roommate
starts with--
[CLEARS THROAT] maybe I'm
catching what Susan has.
You forgot to say that.
Oh, and the way you
told that story,
I don't think it really worked.
And why did you wear
that white jacket?
You know?
ERIN SCHAEFER: Because
it looks great.
It looks great.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: But
you know what I'm saying?
ERIN SCHAEFER: Instead
of focusing on the fun,
you focus on all
the little things.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: All these
things which are meaningless.
And is anybody
recognizing the voice?
ERIN SCHAEFER: Yes.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
So let's just
all make this
decision that we don't
take this voice seriously.
It's not the truth.
It's not who we are.
We can just treat
it like a child.
You know when your
child says something
and he throws a temper tantrum?
You don't have to
actually act on it.
ERIN SCHAEFER: Right.
I shouldn't, in fact.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Especially
the two-and-a-half-year-old.
ERIN SCHAEFER: Yes.
Yes.
Arianna, I wanted to ask--
because you also brought up
your mother and her teaching
you that you could-- failure
would be OK.
And that you, as a woman,
would still be able to succeed.
You've been a female leader
in a very traditionally
male-dominated industry.
And I know we have all
sorts of folks here today,
but there are a lot of people
from our Women@ group at Google
here and a lot of people
listening on the GVC.
So I'm wondering if you have
any advice for the women here
and beyond Google who are
often in a similar situation
where they're in a
male-dominated industry--
how to think about
showing up there.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
Well, I feel that we
have a great opportunity--
as we were talking,
actually, beforehand--
for women not just to take
our place at the top of the
world in every profession,
but to actually--
including the White House--
but to actually change
the way the world works.
Because right now, the way
work places have been designed
and the work world
has been designed,
has been designed by man.
And it's not functioning well.
It's not really good for
anybody, including polar bears.
And I think women have
a greater opportunity
to lead the way here.
So I feel it's not just about
having the careers we want
and knowing that we can have any
job and any position we want.
But also doing it differently.
Because there is a lot of pain
and suffering in the world that
we cannot immediately change.
But this is some
pain and suffering
that we can immediately
change, simply
by that cultural revolution
that we are talking about
of moving away
from this delusion
that we need to
burnout to succeed.
And men are going to
be incredibly grateful.
Because look at last year
alone at the number of men
who collapsed on their
treadmills and either
died or ended up
with heart attacks.
Because what's happening
is that we've all
accepted-- whether we do
it or not-- that exercise
and nutrition are important.
But this third pillar is sleep.
And you have all these
sleep-deprived, type A
executives getting up
at the crack of dawn
to get their workout in.
When, in fact, I urge
you to just sleep in.
When you are sleep
deprived, that's
more important than
dealing with that deficit.
And then you'll have
a lot more energy,
even if you do a shorter
workout or even if you skip it.
You just need to look at
the science of how essential
that is.
And all these conversations
happening in the workplace
changing the way
workplaces are designed--
of course, at Google,
you're ahead of the curve,
but so many other places are
not-- are Going to be key.
And I'd love women, in
whatever field they are,
to also take that into
account and to do it openly.
Susan and I were
in Davos together.
And we happened to be sitting
next to each other at a dinner
and she was telling me how
she was pumping because she
had just had her fifth child.
And she said she goes back
to the hotel and she pumps
and then she leaves
it out in the snow.
Because she didn't
have a fridge.
ERIN SCHAEFER: Very creative.
She must have had enough
sleep to have a creative idea.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
And then I said, well,
you have to take a picture
and Instagram it, I said.
Because it would be
so great for this.
And she did.
I don't know if
you saw it, but it
was so great to have
this powerful, woman
executive who is also a
mother and is pumping.
She didn't Instagram
herself pumping,
she just-- she just Instagrammed
the milk in the snow.
And I think that the
more openly women
navigate their different
responsibilities
and the more they
actually make it
about a ruthless prioritization,
rather than the juggling
act that drives us all
crazy, the more we'll
be able to change
the culture faster.
ERIN SCHAEFER: Wonderful.
So we should be ourselves--
bring ourselves to work.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Yes.
Our full selves.
ERIN SCHAEFER: My
last question for you
before I turn it over
to the audience here
and to the folks that have been
asking questions on our Dory
is really just this-- you
have accomplished so much.
What is next for you?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
I didn't think
there was going to be a next
after the Huffington Post.
But in fact, "Thrive" and
"The Sleep Revolution"
have led to so many amazing
conversations for me
in so many companies
and with so many people
that I've decided to launch
a new company, Thrive Global,
which is going to be about
going into corporations
and helping them
change the culture
around these principles.
And actually ending
this delusion
that there is a trade-off
between productivity
and well-being.
And seeing that the two are, in
fact, incredibly interconnected
and making all our
offerings, trainings,
courses, very science-based.
And then measuring the
impact of everything
we're doing with these two
key metrics-- health care
costs and productivity.
Because I think the key to
accelerating this revolution
is impacting the bottom line.
ERIN SCHAEFER: Absolutely.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: And helping
people recognize that, in fact,
the well-being of
employees is really
tied to the health
of the bottom line.
And a pioneer in this
area is Mark Bertolini,
the CEO of Aetna, who's
actually going to be joining
the board of my new company.
And I don't know if you saw
the latest thing he's done.
He introduced this
program at Aetna,
and employees are given
Fitbits to track their sleep.
And if they get seven hours
or more for 20 nights,
they are given $300.
ERIN SCHAEFER: Wow.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: It's not
just the financial incentive.
Can you imagine
how revolutionary
that is that the CEO of
a Fortune 500 company
is telling you that
getting enough sleep
is good for business?
ERIN SCHAEFER: Fantastic.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: It's
good for the shareholders.
And then, he always
brings in Duke University
or some scientific center
to measure the impact
on productivity and
health care costs.
So for me, that
will revolutionize
how workplaces
function and that will
make it much easier to
change lives and reduce
all that unnecessary
pain and suffering.
ERIN SCHAEFER: Well, we
can't wait to see it.
And we make sure that you
get to talk to Sundar, Lazlo,
and Eileen about this
idea with the FitBits.
Thank you, Arianna.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Thank you.
ERIN SCHAEFER:
With that, I would
love to invite folks from the
audience here in San Bruno
to come up to the mics with
any questions for Arianna.
We'll first take one live here
and then we'll go to our Dory.
Any brave souls want to
ask Arianna a question?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
And let us know--
ERIN SCHAEFER: Here.
Sorry, there's a mic right--
you probably can't see it.
It's right in the middle
of the room over here.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: And
let us know your name
and what you're doing.
ERIN SCHAEFER: Yes, please.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
If you want, you
can tell us how many hours'
sleep you got last night.
ERIN SCHAEFER: Last night.
If you want to say how
much you got last night.
AUDIENCE: I didn't
get enough last night.
I'm Erin.
I lead our product team for
our consumer music area.
And I'm actually working on
trying to get more sleep.
But it's really hard.
My question for you--
you touched on earlier
how the post is
covering the election
and taking more of a
perspective of sometimes
there isn't two
sides to a story.
And what I've noticed, and
it's been talked about,
is how people can very
easily, now, find content that
reinforces their own views.
And so there's
this echo chamber,
where instead of going
to a central news source,
people just share things.
And it seems to be driving
more of a divide in opinion--
public opinion.
And so I'm curious
what you think.
What are some of
the things that we
can do to impact that
in a positive way?
Because it seems to
be driving people
to more extreme point of
view-- extreme points of view,
and I'm curious to
your thoughts on that.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Thank you.
Well, first of all-- before
I answer that-- can I
give you just one very, very
simple tip about getting
more sleep tonight?
AUDIENCE: That sounds great.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: And
since you have the book,
you'll see the second
part of the book
is all about best practices
and simple tips and techniques.
But please don't go
to straight to that
because the key thing
is to convince yourself
by reading all the latest
scientific findings
of how important it is.
Because once you change your
mind about its importance,
it will be easier to
change your habits.
But the most important,
nonnegotiable thing
is creating a little
transition to sleep.
That's what we've
lost in modern times.
And you still have
young children,
so you know that you don't
just drop your child in bed.
Some nights you
may wish you would.
ERIN SCHAEFER: I wish, but no.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: You give it
a bath, you put it in its PJs,
you sing it a lullaby.
So we need to do the
equivalent with ourselves.
Each person's ritual
will be different.
But it's creating your
own "Goodnight, Moon."
Goodnight laptop,
goodnight smartphone.
You escort them out
of your bedroom.
That's the first key thing.
Because we're all
addicted to our devices.
Let's admit it.
So they have to sleep
separately from you.
And that's the first
nonnegotiable tip.
And then there are
many, many, many others.
But creating that
little ritual, even
if you started with a
5, 10 minute demarcation
line between your
day life-- with all
our inevitable challenges and
obstacles and incompletions--
and the time for us
to sleep and recharge.
Mine is 30 minutes now.
And I describe it in the book.
It's going to make an
incredible difference.
AUDIENCE: I'll
definitely try that.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
Back to politics.
I feel that that's
definitely an issue,
but I think the bigger
issue is that we
are losing respect for facts.
You see, I think that
it's perfectly OK
to have divergent opinions.
But we cannot have a different
set of facts that we base these
opinions on.
So when Hillary Clinton,
in her speech yesterday,
said I believe in
science, that should not
be a point of contrast
between two candidates.
And I think that's
really where we
need to be much more adamant
and much more absolute.
What is the fact
behind this opinion?
And I think that will
help close the divide
we are experiencing right now.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Thank you.
ERIN SCHAEFER:
Arianna, I'm going
to take a question from
our-- because we've
got so many people around the
globe interested in seeing
this and asking questions.
Here's one that we have,
which is-- what role, Arianna,
do you see live
streaming playing
in all media in the future?
And in general, what
has driven your decision
to either leverage
an industry platform
versus build one yourself?
And the example here that the
question-asker gave was you
spent-- I, of course lost the
question-- you spent resources
to build a player for
Huff Po live instead
of utilizing a free solution.
So how do you decide to build
yourself versus use somebody
else's?
And how important do
you think live is?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
We think live
is more and more important.
And we're very-- in fact,
we considered, with Susan,
doing part of this conversation
on your new offering--
your live offering.
We're doing a lot
with Facebook Live.
We're doing a lot on Snapchat.
And we also have our
own Huff Post live.
Again, we're very agnostic.
We want to be on every platform.
And we want to be
on every platform
in ways that are appropriate
to that platform.
For example, for
one day, we took
over a pop-up discover
channel on Snapchat.
Called it Recharge
and it was all
around sleep and recharging.
And it was amazing.
It was funny.
It was all about--
a kind of message
that would appeal
to millennials,
and would not be
eat your broccoli.
And make it sexy and
fun and give them
all the stats about how
getting enough sleep
deals with erectile
dysfunction, for example.
Did you know that?
And so made it appropriate
to the platform
and it had incredible
engagement.
So that's why we need to
be agnostic to the platform
instead of expecting us
all-- expecting everybody
to go to Huff Post live.
ERIN SCHAEFER: But you think
live is increasingly important.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Yes.
I think--
ERIN SCHAEFER: And you
guys are investing in it.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Absolutely.
And I think livestream
is very important.
And even live events are
incredibly important.
I remember there was a
time when we thought nobody
would go to anything live.
All of you could be
watching this on livestream
but you chose to come here.
I think the live stream is going
to be more and more important.
And live events
will we always be
important because-- especially
the more technology dominates
our lives, the more
we actually still want
that direct connection.
ERIN SCHAEFER: Yes.
Thank you.
We will take a question
from the crowd.
SCOTT: Hi, Arianna.
My name is Scott.
I'm on the partnerships
team here at YouTube.
And last night I
slept for six hours.
Piggy-backing off of
the last live question,
in this presidential
election, where
you have a lot of the rhetoric
on one side being based
around fear and anger and
not around facts-- which
is something that you were
saying Hillary Clinton
was trying to reinforce the fact
that she believes in science.
It's hard to believe that
that's an argument that we're
making in 2016.
What role and responsibility
do we play in media companies
like Huffington Post,
YouTube-- other platforms
around the world-- in
combating fear and anger
and things that are
emotion-based-- and so strongly
emotionally-based--
as opposed to things
that aren't rooted in fact?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
Well, I love the fact
that Susan called on
everybody to use the platform
to express their views after
all this explosion of violence.
And to actually recognize that
you are offering a very, very
powerful tool.
And more and more
people need to use it.
And so this is not a
time to sit things out.
And for me, this election
will be decided, in the end,
by who turns out to vote.
And anything that
the platform can
do to reinforce that, you
don't have to tell them
how to vote, obviously.
But to make them recognize
that this is not an election
to sit out and say, I don't
really like any-- either
of the candidates very much.
Because this is really
an existential threat
to our democracy and people
need to take a stand.
And they can take
a stand, obviously,
by creating content-- by
expressing themselves,
by sharing things that they feel
express their point of view--
and by voting.
And the more we can
get that message out
to all the different
demographics that
are on YouTube,
the more powerfully
we can influence the outcome.
SCOTT: Thank you.
ERIN SCHAEFER: I
can speak for Google
and say-- and YouTube--
and say that we
are very committed to it using
our resources to help get out
the vote.
So they'll be a lot of
efforts here in the US,
on YouTube and across
Google, to make sure
that people get to get
out to vote and express
their opinions.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
That's fantastic.
And I'm saying-- I'm
on the board of Uber
and we were having a
board meeting yesterday
and we were talking about free
Uber rides to go to the polls.
Whatever-- maybe Airbnb can-- if
you have travel to another city
to vote, maybe Airbnb can
help subsidize where you stay.
Basically, every company
needs to do what they can
to encourage people to vote.
Because it's absurd how many
millions and millions of people
did not vote in
the last election.
If we can change
that, it will have
a huge impact on our democracy.
I'm very happy to hear that.
ERIN SCHAEFER: Absolutely.
Changing gears a little
bit-- back to wellness--
and this is something you and
I talked about this morning
so I really want you to share
your point of view here.
The question that we have from
somebody outside the office
is, it seems easy to advocate
for slowing down and getting
seven to eight hours of
sleep once you've made it.
But how do you
counter the perception
that you have to put in
time and sleep deprivation
before earning the ability
to have a work life and sleep
balance?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
Well, thank you so
much for asking this question.
Because my obnoxious
roommate, if we had not
dealt with this topic, would
have told me afterwards,
you should have
addressed that fact.
Because that is a very
important fact and that's
exactly what has led
to the founder myth.
The idea that if you are
the founder of a company
or if you are starting
in your career,
you have to outwork
everybody and just pay
your dues and all these things.
And it is scientifically false.
That doesn't mean that a lot
of people who have succeeded
haven't been sleep-deprived
and exhausted along the way.
It is.
Because up until now, everybody
since the first industrial
revolution, has been living and
working under this delusion.
But it is not only unnecessary,
but counterproductive.
Let me just give you an example.
We all know the stat--
3/4 of start-ups fail.
Start-up founders are
exhausted and sleep-deprived.
Hey, maybe there is
a correlation here.
Maybe we can change the stat.
Because there's no question
that our cognitive performance
is degraded when
we're exhausted.
So that's why
understanding the science
is so key to changing
that cultural perception.
There was actually a great study
that came out in the "Harvard
Business Review" by McKinsey--
too late to include in my book,
but it will be in the paperback.
A McKinsey study and the
title, you would have thought
was out of The Onion.
The title was "The Proven Link
Between Effective Leadership
and Sleep."
Now, can you imagine that
study even two years ago?
And they walk you
through all the science
of what happens to
your prefrontal cortex
when you are sleep-deprived and
how it affects your decision
making.
And how it affects your capacity
to lead and to be empathetic
and to build teams
and to inspire.
And all the things that
are essential to leaders.
ERIN SCHAEFER: Absolutely.
I think we have another
question here in San Bruno.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Arianna.
I'm Daniel from the
living room team.
I got about seven hours
of sleep last night.
I was curious your thoughts,
if you had any-- recently
it's come out that
Peter Thiel, who
is a luminary figure
in the valley,
but not without
controversy, has been
bankrolling a number of
lawsuits against Gawker Media.
The Supreme Court has told
us that money equals speech,
so he's certainly entitled
to do as he wishes.
But I'm curious if
you had thoughts
on one billionaire trying to
take down a media company,
irrespective of whether it's
a muckraker site or whatnot.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON:
I actually believe
that it's not the
role of billionaires
to try and take down sites.
I think it is even
more dangerous
when billionaires running
for president talk
about punishing media.
And I think that's really
infinitely more dangerous.
And Donald Trump
has said many times
that-- not only has he
demonstrated it already
by removing credentials
from the Huffington Post,
from "The Washington Post,"
from many media operations that
have taken very strong
stances against him--
or simply point out the facts.
Again, "The Washington Post"
stories that made him so upset
were not even-- were
not opinion-driven.
They were fact-driven.
And Peter Thiel also
speaking at the convention
is something that I
don't understand at all.
Maybe he did not read the
platform on gay rights.
But people just need to try to
be more consistent about all
these issues.
And ultimately,
freedom of expression
includes acknowledging that a
lot of things being expressed
are not going to
be to my liking.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Thank you.
ERIN SCHAEFER: I think we have
another question coming up here
in San Bruno.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hello, Arianna.
My name's Arnum.
I'm from people operations team.
I'm a huge fan of yours.
I've been reading the
Huff Post since 2005.
I read it every day.
And the last night, I
think I got seven hours.
But usually when I'm
trying to go to sleep,
I'm usually reading
the Huffington Post.
But I'll try to read it
around 9:00 and then quit.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Yes.
Exactly.
Just leave a little
break between the two.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So first off, thank
you so much for coming.
It's great to see you in person.
I have a question
about the media.
It was reported, I think,
in 2000-- or excuse me,
in March 2016 that Bush
had-- not Bush-- sorry
I'm a little nervous.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: No problem.
AUDIENCE: It was reported
by "The New York Times"
that Trump had almost $2
billion of free media coverage.
And then, a couple other things
that have been interesting
is in the 2000
presidential election,
the media declared
Bush the winner
before the votes in
Florida were even counted.
And then, also, this
last election cycle-- I
was a little bit upset when
California hadn't voted yet
and the media declared
Clinton the winner
of the Democratic nomination.
So I'm just curious
what your thoughts are
about the political manipulation
that's happening with the media
and how they're changing public
opinion and things like that.
And maybe how we
can counter that.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Well,
absolutely great question.
And I'm very troubled
by the media's role,
especially in this
election cycle.
There was actually a great
study by the Shorenstein Center
at Harvard about how effectively
the media dramatically
helped Donald Trump
win the nomination.
Because at the
beginning, when they
were giving him this
amazing amount of coverage--
that, as you said, was the
equivalent of $2 billion
in free advertising-- there
was not justification for it.
He was not ahead in the polls.
He had not to build
the kind of fundraising
or organizational
teams that would make
him a legitimate candidate.
So it was purely
because of ratings.
And they even
allowed him to phone
in to major political shows,
including the Sunday shows,
which never happens.
And so a lot of what the
media have been doing
has been ratings-driven,
rather than driven
by basic journalistic ethics.
And we've done a lot of coverage
on that again and again.
And it's also a
recognition that,
for me, came very
much to the forefront
when I was giving a
commencement speech at Fletcher,
which is a foreign
service school at Tufts.
And it also houses the
Edward Murrow papers.
And I was talking to the
head of the Murrow Center
about how would he have
handled Donald Trump
and he said he would
have skewered him.
And if you go back and see
how Murrow handled McCarthy,
this is not the time
to actually hold back.
And far too many
journalists, even
the way they are covering these
conventions, focusing on things
that are legitimizing the entire
charade of the Trump candidacy,
shows that these are all
ratings-driven decisions.
Nothing else.
I don't think there is
some deep manipulation
behind these decisions, except
that when Donald Trump was
on "Meet the Press," it was
the biggest rating bonanza
that Chuck Todd had.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Thank you.
ERIN SCHAEFER: Well,
Chuck Todd is not
letting him call in
anymore, and we can all
be very proud of Chuck, who's
one of my favorite journalists.
One last question,
Arianna, because we're
at the end of our time, sadly.
But I want to get back
to wellness and Thrive.
So one last question from
here was, how important
is napping to productivity
and well-being?
And have you seen
examples of napping
being incorporated and
integrated successfully
into a company's culture?
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Yes.
First of all, napping
is incredibly important.
Now, if you've
gotten all the sleep
you need, which-- just to remind
you-- is seven to nine hours,
unless you have a
genetic mutation.
ERIN SCHAEFER: Which is
only one in 100 people,
so you are unlikely to
have that genetic mutation.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: But I'm
sure one or two of you here do.
And you know that, and
if you don't know that,
you can test yourself.
But having said that,
napping is amazing.
If you didn't get enough
sleep, for whatever
reason-- and that's
always going to happen.
You have a sick child,
you have a big deadline,
your flight was late--
then try and get a nap
as soon as possible in the day.
Even a 20-minute nap is
unbelievably restorative.
Winston Churchill regularly
napped and won the Second World
War.
And called them power naps.
At the Huffington Post,
we have two nap rooms
and they're always full.
I know here, you have
a lot of nap pods.
ERIN SCHAEFER: We do.
And nap rooms in almost
every office, yes.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: And here at
YouTube , you have a nap room?
ERIN SCHAEFER: We do.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Great.
Does everybody know
where the nap room is?
ERIN SCHAEFER: We have
nap pods and rooms.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Great.
I think that-- I'm predicting
that within the next five
years, the nap
room is going to be
as universal as the
conference room.
In every company, not
just pioneering companies
like Google and YouTube.
The thing that we
need to recognize
is that even the middle of
the afternoon, or at any point
you feel really
tired, there's nothing
that's going to increase
your productivity as
fast as a little nap.
And it's going to
dramatically transform
how we handle these
afternoon low points,
where normally, we go for the
fifth cup of coffee or a donut
or whatever it is
to get some energy.
This is all part of the culture
change that is happening.
And that I hope,
with your help--
you're amazing creators
and leaders in our culture.
So you have an incredible power
to accelerate a cultural change
that's already
happening and that's
going to bring some amazing
change in people's lives.
And we'd love to hear from
you on the Huffington Post.
You can send me
anything you want--
arianna@huffingtonpost.com.
We'd love to post it.
And of course, you can
crosspost it anywhere,
including on that
little platform
you work for called YouTube.
ERIN SCHAEFER: Well, Arianna we
cannot wait to see what you do
with Thrive.
Thank you so much for
being with us here today.
ARIANNA HUFFINGTON: Thank you.
Thank you.
And can we please give me
a round of applause to you?
Because you did such a
great job stepping in.
ERIN SCHAEFER:
Thank you, Arianna.
In your honor, let's
all try to get seven
to nine hours of sleep
tonight and beyond, everyone.
Thank you so much.